I think I struggled for a minute with
finding something to do on my own and
what was I gonna do I knew I was
passionate about makeup but I didn't
know I could have fun every day doing my
job I'm Kylie Jenner and I am the
founder of Kylie cosmetics I had an
insecurity with my lips when I was
younger so I turned to makeup to help me
feel more confident I went to the makeup
store and I just like I didn't even know
really what colors I was picking I was
just like I want some lip liner that
looks like the color of my lips because
I just want my lips to look fuller but I
could never find a lip liner and a
lipstick that matched or even the right
color that was perfect for me so that's
where the lip kit started I was so
focused on like formula and color but
everything else just kind of fell into
place I put so much love into everything
that I make and I make sure everything
is perfect and something I would
personally use so then when I see my
fans have it and they love it and their
reaction that's what's the most exciting
to me starting a company on my own and
it being so big from the beginning
there's not a lot of room for mistakes
every company has mistakes they learn
from them and they change them but it's
probably owning up to those from the
beginning and just being honest and
changing them in front of everybody
I'm the face to my brand and I take
responsibility for everything that
happens
I haven't learned everything from my mom
yet that I know that I need to she
teaches me something new every day about
everything
she is my goals and I'm just each day
I'm like trying to take it all in she's
definitely been a huge part of the
success of Kylie cosmetics if I could
give some advice let's do something that
you love if you're building something
from the ground up
like do something that you're passionate
about so you just have fun every day and
you love what you do
you